they are putting the people of this
country everyday Americans absolutely at
the bottom of the barrel and they're
putting themselves first
AOC uh here she is uh well basically
explaining that Republicans are bad
because they're into impeachment
something that she was into for an awful
long time when there was a certain
orange man that was
president what they're using and what
they're doing is taking impeachment and
taking all of the most serious
procedures that we have as a country and
they're learning to use for political
they're politically weaponizing it for
an election purpose for a political
purpose and in doing so they are putting
the people of this country everyday
Americans absolutely at the bottom of
the barrel and they're putting
themselves first it's a selfishness that
that really endangers this country it
endangers our electoral process it
endangers our legal process it's deeply
cynical and it's done to reelect
themselves and line their own pockets
all right as you know everything she
just said Republicans are doing is
exactly what Democrats did when Trump
was President right two impeachments
nobody even remembers what they were for
both of them failed obviously one of
them the the January 6th one he was
already leaving like he was on the way
out anyway just utterly pointless and
utter waste of time and money and brain
power and everything else and there's
not a lot of brain power with that woman
um so when she talks about Republicans
politically weaponizing things for their
own benefits it's the Democrats who
literally right now as we speak who are
trying to remove Donald Trump off the
ballot that is I would say a mild case
of political weaponization do you think
uh anyway here's a bit more because as
you know when the Democrats don't get
the way they uh don't get things the way
they want them uh then they try to
destroy the institutions too uh here's a
AOC on well maybe just removing Clarence
Thomas from the Supreme Court
so why do you think he should he should
recuse himself I mean I think it it's
very clear Clarence Thomas and rather
his wife Jenny participated in the
events of January 6th and now what is
likely going before The Supreme Court is
a judgment as to whether an event that
his wife participated in that his wife
has been investigated by in the January
6 Committee in qualifies as an
Insurrection and Clarence Thomas's
decision on that one way or another and
overall the Court's decision on that
would directly implicate his wife and so
this is just one of the most classic
textbook conflicts of interest uh and it
would frankly be a scandal if he did not
recuse do you think what an what an
absolute farce and I did watch the
extended version of that he offers no
push back Anderson Cooper offers no push
back he is just a corporate mouthpiece
that is all he is you see what AOC did
there at first At first she tried to
imply that Clarence Thomas himself had
something to do the with the
Insurrection then she backtracks says
it's all about Jenny Thomas again what
she's referring to is that these cases
in Colorado and where's the other one um
and Maine where they've removed Donald
Trump from the ballot for Insurrection
something he hasn't been convicted of
that's going to obviously those cases
will work their way up to the Supreme
Court and I just have no doubt that the
Supreme Court is going to do the right
thing and reverse them but she wants
Clarence Thomas to recuse himself from
that because she doesn't like Clarence
Thomas because she doesn't like an up
black guy who doesn't think the way she
thinks